[Music]
hey guys how are you this is chris cross
pleasure to meet you i'm a comic book
artist i've been working in the industry
for about 30 years now
for the most part they're working with
dc commerce and having time in my life
to find that as a little boy that when
you grow up you're going to be working
with a company that's going to be
producing batman
and all those great characters what an
amazing dream come true
right what's even better is when you
apply yourself
you want to go get what you want you're
surprised what shows up
i've been very blessed to work with some
talented very intelligent
very genius type of uh artists who
continue to push my ability to
to do my craft to the next level brian
david marshall
never get that brother told me about a
company that was being created by some
black writers and artists
those people were derek dingle dwayne
mcduffie dennis cowan
and michael davis and working with
milestone in my first time out talking
about trial about fire
and having to maintain that while he was
still going to college and making
deadlines
i can tell you the many places we were
able to go together in a lot of ways
almost felt like
being in those books i was in a place
where very few people were able to get
to and everyone wanted to graduate to
that particular venue
everyone who showed up there wanted to
stay there that's the place you want to
be where
so cohesive is so few of such energy
that you just want to create and when
you create
you create beautiful things people of
color
or part of the whole situation was
actually flowed into the books
which created such a statement that it
became the
talk of the industry and not just any
industry every industry
we became the gold standard
being able to be represented as a
culture in books
it's very very uh important thing people
want to be known
as someone that exists someone that's
been studying someone that's been
looked into they want to know about your
tradition they want to know about your
history
and you don't really get to know about
people like that unless
they're been depicted to know that
being represented also means that
i myself as a african american can
actually be a part of that situation
so when we're drawing and they cut these
books when they realize that crisscross
is a black man
who came from a particular part of new
york city you know you could come from
anywhere and be able to reach your goals
and it gives them some sort of light
some sort of faith they can do it
also and that's what we're all about we
want to get the kind of equilibrium
across a medium so that everyone feels
they have a voice
[Music]
i'm glad that they're coming back dc is
going to be publishing
a new era of the dakota verse milestone
returns
zero is out three headlining books
that's coming out through milestone
which is
hardware icon rocket and static now
static
i mentioned this because i'm also
working on static with a really great
artist named
nicholas draper ivy
do me a favor continue to keep reading
comic books continue to keep supporting
us
we really need you we're competing with
comics and we're competing with anime
you want to pass yourself on to your
kids
get their vocabulary up so that people
can continue to enjoy the
process of reading and or opening your
imagination great and new possibilities
you want to bring everyone to the
barbecue bring your ribs
and bring your napkins we're going to be
getting you salivate in the next couple
of months
i enjoy you guys i love you guys stay
safe
keep hope alive take it easy
you